hello and welcome to this video playing
a SF from the US yes I want to do
something else let's play the eloquence
Oh c4m hmm yeah they're taking looks
looks wrong deform divorce and dishes
maybe maybe let's try that it isolates
his pawn on e5 also a bit so that could
become a target on the other hand
something I guess exactly Bishop d3
Bishop you form looks quite okay for
white so it cannot be bad for him or
anything p okay so hmm I think I'm
taking him and now try to play against
the c5 porn maybe it's going to should
be four nope yeah okay I can't play g6
Bishop g7 bit and you can know will
protect this quite reliably so it's
difficult to actually win the pawn and
you can play 22 or queen g3
oh not easy and he's got h4 h5 that's
also part of this position hmm yeah that
doesn't look so great yeah what to do
here I try to do something it would be
five but yeah this is something that I
had expected but wasn't quite sure how
to react if i go h6 year i think i'll
try h6e I possible f4 is so it's maybe
coming I want some counter player
definitely so this is why I go b5 and
see you that I can maybe provoke
something on the queenside yeah that is
not easily provoked top take em I can
all night 85 try to yeah maybe that's
interesting
night only five doesn't look too
brilliant now and I would like to get it
to to to d5 that would be good so Knight
to c6 the first step to this but this
position looks very shaky I feel like
I'm in trouble him k f4 is probably his
IDM gym
poor not a happy movement
okay maybe get the Rope tf8 poor
yeah this is also easy to play maybe
maybe if he goes rock g3 he lost me at
five I can even take that Queen air for
the Sochi seven checkmate oh my god
that's so awful i was thinking rook g3
f5 takes Queen air for but you can play
rook g7 mate so pretty pretty amazing
yeah Wow absolutely awful there any way
to fight here at least a little bit
Wow
I know black resigns yeah this is what
happened there when you play some crap
opening it you're not good at it I mean
okay that's a bit too much the alec is
not not a bad opening itself but it just
it's not my position I probably have to
go h5 him this is probably not so bad
but it's can it is not good you have
less space center I have to go age five
each six is probably worse and now maybe
adenoma this is so far too ambitious or
so and f4 really hit very hard the
computer is totally relaxed about it
here and wants to Castle so here 96 so
what the engine wants to play at it
still looks super dangerous and it's
still not a good position the engine
maybe gives equal but I don't don't
quite don't quite get it Jim now you
place those Muslim
I know before I can go night seafoam
that's nothing it's nothing special i'm
more afraid of stuff on the kingside my
king is really really a bit weak I don't
think before sir it's a dangerous
business yeah that's the problem area
players I'm opening and the position
type is just not not my cup of tea
you're sitting there against the c5 pawn
all the time out here it's almost losing
king of a probably was rubbish ready but
it's it's it's not fun to play this
position you have no space why these two
bishops and you're sitting there yeah
okay thanks for watching